друзі сьогодні день святого Миколая і він
приніс багатьом хорошим хлопчиком солодощі
є поганий хлопчик коля коля тищенко
який знову себе виявив у своєму
інтерв'ю на країну їй і ось а взагалі-то
про мене питали він почав відповідати
про шановну прекрасну чудову
Іру Геращенко про кита матраци згадав
але загалом те, що послуг на умі одні
матраци ми знаємо ще починаючи з історією
про синю бороду
богдана яременка але тепер нам відкрилися
нові глибини мислення та свідомості таких
товаришів як валите цуценя в загальному холі
ти припиняй я вже тебе сказав що скоро
ставити таблички ревізор
рекомендує в сизо припиняючись
займатися нісенітницею не чіпай дівчат
чудових якщо є якісь питання
підходь поговоримо а дівчат не чіпай і
пам'ятай будеш себе добре поводити через рік
тобі святий Миколай щось принесе
неважливо раптом може і в сезон про принесе